i' made the same that's we'll make a
start
um fellow councilors and me um welcome
to the finance and projects meeting for
today 17th of October um we are on live
stream and welcome to those people who
are joining us on live stream and with
those people have joined us on the
public G Gallery um do we have any
apologies
Trish oil and committee Trish yeah just
noting those not committee members but
noting both of those parties yeah Trish
and
P um we
receive yeah okay any Declarations of
Interest anyone would like to
declare okay no thank you uh public
forum we don't have anyone who's
registered for public forum just
clarified with Michael around if we have
someone that turns up um and would like
to speak in public forum it is at the um
cheers discretion but usually we prefer
to have notification of that so we can
clarify with um which you know they
speaking to the right Committee in
effect so just an for me and anyone else
who's
interested um right so the first piece
of businesses confirm the minutes of the
finance and projects meeting for the
15th of August can we have move thank
you Darren and second thanks Barry uh
any discussions on those minutes before
we okay there being none um all those in
favor of accepting those I I against
carried thank you um next on the agenda
is the long-term plan assumptions 20124
to
2034 and Patricia is going to take us
through these I was I was looking for
Ranon but she was here and has just
disappeared um so counselors this is um
you some of you have already seen um
this paper it's very similar to what
went to infrastructure last week in
relation to the assumptions that related
to infrastructure this is looking at the
assumptions as they relate to the
finance committee um these will be
coming through to council so this is the
assumptions that we want to uh putting
are forming the basis of a modeling for
the long-term
plan and I will leave it there if
there's any and take any
questions so I think these are very
similar to the ones we workshopped they
are very similar this is not the first
time you will have seen these they were
workshopped they've come through
infrastructure they're coming through
here in finance we will still be
tweaking some of the financial
assumptions as we go through the ltp we
are waiting for new inflation numbers
from B they are going to do another cut
during
November um but as things move markets
move interest rates may
change um then we can do that yes
technical
issues I I did wonder whether the ipet
died on the way it has D welcome R do
you want to add anything further to the
assumptions or you happy to listen to
the discussion no I'm happy to take
questions okay M CL did you hand I just
going to move the two recommendations
all right okay was there any further
discussion before we do that okay second
them okay thank you M Clark and seconded
lesle any further discussion okay all
those in favor I I against
carried okay next uh the capital
projects report
Lee
not
here's having iPad trouble who
knows you want have move to the
financial update yeah we might yeah
we'll go we'll skip on to um Tab 7 which
is the financial update where we wait
for Le to turn
up um so this is is Jamie coming down or
no I'm doing it the team sorry and
apologies from the team um they're busy
doing um ltp budgeting and in a report
so it's uh
I've left it to the boss to do today um
so this is the position of where we sit
at 30 September in relation to um a net
debt and Treasury and there is some
explanation in there as well about where
we sit at August on the other numbers
you will get at the next meeting of this
committee the performance for the first
quarter so to the end of
September so our net debt is sitting at
62 million it's where was within the the
the maximums that we've
set and we've just included all the
other breakdowns um with them there and
I'm happy to take
questions on any that anyone has okay M
CLK yeah on on page
36 um where it talks about cash and cash
Investments that that figure of 61
million that's reasonably comparable to
what we had this time last year more in
the bank and less in investment but now
it's the other way
around um um it's it's just gone around
at the moment because we've just uh
we've just had a couple of turn deposits
also the turn deposit rate is a little
bit higher than what it was at this time
last year so we have taken the
opportunity to put some short-term term
deposits in place just to pack up that
um slightly better interest rate uh so
on page 38 which is the following page
which talks about employee
expenses uh and we've got an under spend
of nearly half a million
um I guess I'm trying to understand uh
what we do with the annual plan forecast
which is the middle column there the
5 098 million in
there um and I think I've raised this
before in the past um it seems to me
that one of the issues that we sometimes
do is we sometimes forecast ahead in the
next year for our salaries based on us
having reasonbly full quoter of St
when in fact we know that we don't
necessarily end up in that
position um and so um I just wonder
whether because when you look at that
you'd think well it's good that we've
underspent but it might just be that
we've over over forecast in the first
place as well so through your chair the
um aspect of that is that we do and when
we do budget our salaries and wages
numbers we do include an allowance for a
percentage of vacancies yeah so that's
fact that what that difference will be
at this time of the year is simply that
annual plan for August year to date to
August is divided by 12 times by two and
that's not what the actual numbers will
be given the number of pay Cycles we
will have been through year to
date so it's a timing difference y so on
the same page when it goes down to talk
about consultancy expenses we've got an
overspend there of well over forecast um
have $110,000 so um just helped me out
consultancy expenses also cover what
some people might call contractors who
are people that might be
filling uh positions that would
otherwise be filled by
staff no they should be sitting on a
different line
okay any more questions no oh sorry I've
still got a few um on the following page
which is 39 it talks about um non rates
non rate debtors that have an
outstanding 1.4 million of debt that we
have owing to us does that include
parking fines on an ongoing basis and
and what level do we have of parking
fines that are
outstanding my understanding is that
that would include the parking fines but
I don't have the actual level of debt in
front of me at the moment but we can get
them I think that would be helpful to
know what that is thank you thank you um
Lesley oh sorry Michael had s up sorry
just sure sorry sorry through yourself
CH I just want to come back to that
salary one um to respond to the Mia uh
Justin uh yes there ask while our
Consultants are um not directly um paid
for our staff in relation to that line
there is some work or activity that
we're not able to do via our staff um
that we will actually contract uh
consult that workout in some aspects so
there is an aspect of that which is
offsetting that Staffing um and with
that vacancy allowance we have been on
the negative side in the past in
relation to that I.E we've had a higher
vacancy percentage than what we've had
an allowance for we've now got that very
close to what has been in the plans in
the past so we are now pretty close to
the wire and in relation to what is the
normal vacancy rate across local
government um we'll need to reflect on
that we've been reasonably successful on
on our recruitment strategy um over the
last few while so vacancy numbers have
been
dropping so just a followup question
from that so
we we would allow an air forecasting
some level of contractor SL consultant
as part of our
overall um getting stuff done cost yeah
through S absolutely we would um there's
aspects of our work that we do need
specialist advice yeah but that that
would always be in our forecast yeah
correct thank youly sorry about that
that's fine Mr chair um just page 40
Patricia the water billing information
there that the overdue bills is that
normal for this period of the cycle or
is that slightly concerned about it's
it's looking pretty normal for the
period of cycle yes the numbers are
going up but the water billing typically
it tends to be the commercials just
because of the nature of um their rating
prop their how their properties are
rated so it's it IB and flows so we are
St to see some cycles and we're going to
update these reports so you start to see
some graphs because we now have that
data from a longer period thank you
great Darren no Michael covered off my
question thank you okay uh Ria thank you
Mr chair I'm just um on page 39 of board
diligence and I'm looking under the
subheading of debt write off and
although there's an explanation there
for the debt write off and it's got
couple of figures there um pulled out
from there if it's too expensive for us
to chase out through external debt
recovery businesses what solution has
there been for us to recover that debt
instead of writing it off to get to the
point in which we write it off we have a
often we just you can't find the person
so we use an external Law Firm to do our
debt collection for us they can't find
them we have also extensively in housee
before it even gets there tried to to
find them so we've done as much as we
can okay and then we because it it costs
to just the time
of okay thank you Barry yeah um under
the water the water billing one I notice
there's uh five
customers the bulk of the amount of
387 2 six are we chasing them
indeed are they bowling clubs or um I
can't off the top of my head I don't
recall um who they are okay thank
you okay any other
questions um
everyone um just on page 39 as well
grants and subsidies expenses does that
tend to be heavier at the beginning of
the cycle and tail off and even out over
the year or is this unusual this year
um it's it's pretty similar to what it
is like the team will have tried to plan
it so that but a lot do uplift their
grants right at the start of the Year
where they have a multi-year grant
Arrangement where a lot of it is
uplifted at the front care
that any further
questions okay there being none do we
have move in second no can we get a move
in second to receive the for
update thanks bar and I'll take your
second pleas okay thank you no further
discussion all those in
favor great carried but we'll drop back
to the Strategic
projects paper welcome
Lee you flying along my apologies for
put you out
step all good you want to sort of take
us through the headline and then we can
have a discussion yeah sure I mean I'll
take the report as as it is I'm open for
questions on the dashboard I mean
overall um that program is still taking
along it's an interesting Market out
there we're still starting to see we'
seen a spare share of Interest still in
in our projects some of the pricing is
still um probably a little bit higher
than we really would like it to be but
it's it is starting to shift in the
right direction um we you know we're
still seeing that come through in some
of our
attenders but yeah I think it's stable
and doing okay I think it's probably the
the headline there
good okay
questions Ry um yeah Lee
regarding just looking at the dashboard
for the CCTV and it shows out of the a
million dollar budget we've spent $
51,1 36 correct what what have we got
for that can we physically see something
like as in the file
recommendations what what does 50 Grand
get you because I'd imagine it should
get you quite a bit Yeah I think that's
all that front end um early concept
stuff that investigation uh stuff that's
the um early workshops and presentation
that sa for City's brought to council I
think late February um that's yes really
that conceptual sort of design that in
that uh Discovery phase and um you sort
of that that those staging documents
that were provided yeah sorry that's but
sorry 50 Grand we we surely must have a
folder that's got all you know um
thoughts on you know the network and
whatever and there should be something
we can actually go to for 51 Grand I
mean seriously 51 Grand's quite a quite
a couple of dollars and
which there should be something we can
we can actually refer to look at advice
letters of you know something yeah I
think it's the if you look at the scope
of works that saer City's had for that
initial phase um they've delivered that
phase pretty much on their budget and
they delivered the deliverables that
were set out uh in that RFP so they've
they've provided the services that
they've um set out to do for the fee
that they've set out to do it for and um
yeah 51,00 there's a lot of money but
you know that's there's quite a bit of
Discovery work and uh and concept design
that's been provided uh for that the
reason I'm asking this is we move on to
the next item which you're talking about
CCTV and it
basically is a fresh start now it almost
you'd say that's why I'm asking what did
the 51 get us because we
really when you look at your next item
it it it is basically a fresh start
I think what that um that Discovery
document what that's given you is giving
you a three-year sort of look of what
the CCTV could look like down the track
and it's giving you a staging document
and a conceptual design that says you
know x amount of cameras in this area x
amount of cameras in this area uh these
are the costs for cameras these are the
things to be considering you know it
highlights that there's some issues at
the police station and how you know
server base whether it's server based
cloud-based it's done all that early
thinking it's done all that you know
poll location pieces it's done that
visib you know so you can see the
visibility of where the network would be
it's done that review with police on um
high intensity areas and where they want
to be so I think it's I think it's I
think it's not fair to say that it's not
a lot of work for $50,000 it's it's got
It's got the ground it's got the base
it's got the Bas basic pieces there but
there is quite still quite a lot of work
to do that is true that's fair to say
yeah I wonder can we just maybe what we
might do because we have got the paper
specifically related to CCTV is just
cover off anything else that's on the
Strategic projects oh cool I just I was
preemptive yeah no absolutely no except
they're no good questions it's just okay
so let's get this covered off and then
we can dig a bit deeper into the C TV
project so was there any other questions
in relation to the yeah to the um any
other projects that are on the Strategic
project Tom and then bar thanks so my
question is genetic actually Le does the
um spend to dat include internal charge
out costs or is it all external spending
no that's we capitalize our wages so
it's internal and external it's internal
and external okay what that's only for
the pmo though isn't it correct yeah so
the pmo will capitalize its cost into
the project y but if it's done outside
of the pmo that's not the case is
it not too sure that no know that yeah
um to the extent we've got projects that
are generating Capital um we do charge
the on charge that time
of Staff directly associated with it so
not your Finance back office T but the
designers if it's in the renewal space
within our ESG team or it teams we do do
that you want to add to that yeah
through yourself to just like to add
that for us it's really about those
staff that are working on future
projects um I.E creating assets for the
future um are being capitalized because
that means we're funding and charging
the right rate payers we're not charging
today's rate payers for that work we're
looking at um charging the future rate
payers for an asset that's going to be
Ben of benefit for the future not today
so um we need to do that to make sure we
get the right funding mix in place uh
from that perspective and charge the
right people yeah and it's all it's
fully costing the project is it full
cost did that answer your questions Tom
yeah it does I mean I'm sort of assuming
there for the fairly early stages of
projects there a small small amount of
money on here the majority of that might
well be internal charg rates rather than
you know consultancy and so forth yeah
and the initial F of a project must
would that be feel it yeah as we go
through that early Discovery and go
through that scoping and that sort of
you know the early documentation phase
that would be right
100% Gary yeah as far as the gore Boat
Boat Ramp
goes we've spent four
97 very Bluff sorry yeah we not buring
the G fair enough
just new
project have we have we got a final sort
of figure we were looking at for the
West uh pontoon or uh the West pontoon
so we've got all the Tenders in for our
Civil Works uh for our steel piece we're
just actually waiting for final costes
to come in for the Pu piece which is the
floating piece um yep no what you call
it they've established down on site they
started with piling um all in P yeah the
only last cost um piece we're waiting
for is that pu uh the floating element
we've actually had some initial costings
we we've changed the scope a little bit
and we' put that back to the supplier to
get them to repice that so we're just
waiting for that thank you uh
rain you had a question yeah look it was
regarding like I'm just a bit confused
over that if you've got a million dollar
budget and you're going to say that
potentially half of that could be staff
cost or you know we don't know what the
staff cost is going to be so in real
term Ms we actually don't know what the
budgets actually is because if you're
saying that 51 Grand spent already is
potentially staff
costs then I'm a bit confused and why we
create budgets yeah so couple of things
there probably this predominantly has
been consultant costs when regards to
staff costs we
project the project manager costs into
the into the into budgets at the start
so we do forecast what we'll spend as
staff costs into all projects at the
budgeting stage so it's not a it's not
an open-ended book yeah it's a
methodology that's used in pmo officers
yeah it's you know number of project
managers full-time part-time how many
projects they will have over that over
the over each year so it's not uh it's
not charged up as we go along yeah so if
you think about 1225 so all the cost
associated with Lee and his team's work
involed and that is costed into
initially correct and then it's reviewed
against the actual a speed track we
track that as we go through yeah so it's
a way of truly reflecting the cost to
rate payers of of a project yeah exactly
the same with Consultants you know
certain Consultants work on a certain
per uh percentage base so we can you
know we can surmise what Consultants are
going to cost and you know 1225 is a
great example where we've onboarded
Consultants at each stage and they've
been roughly within that ballpark of
what we've been um estimating so project
management time is done exactly the same
way yeah and it's good it's good project
management yeah methodology yeah lle
thanks Mr chair the I noticed the
housing Innovation project we stood the
site down over the flooding period can
you just give me a little bit more
detail on that yeah just because a lot
yeah a lot of that work is was external
still so we had we haven't got the
buildings absolutely closed in yet so it
was just inappropriate really to have
staff working externally in in the
absolute wet that it was and better off
it's actually the same contractor that's
working on the Tisbury storage facility
so it's much better for us to put those
staff inside Tisbury where they can be a
bit more efficient out of the weather
and it was just a safer and better thing
to do um if we had two separate
contractors might have been a bit
trickier and we might have made a
different sort of call but because we
had the two same contractors working on
two projects we could we could make that
call and it was just better for the
staff well wellbeing and Welfare and a
smart thing to do right thank you I was
just worried if it was a drainage issue
that we had the but obviously yeah just
just a bit just a bit
saf a bit of sensibility and a bit of a
bit of safety y thank
you great thank you Mr chair Le I'm
looking at line to rugby park I'm
looking at the spin to date plus the
forecasted spend and then the comments
on that spend I'm looking at the
contingency that's remaining and I'm
wondering given the explanation the
comments on page 32 and Page 33 if that
contingency is enough cuz it seems to me
reading those comments and looking at
the work and the
specialization that we could run out of
funds there yeah I think that's a that's
a good observation the look The rugby
park is a little bit of a moving moving
Feast at the moment the roof is proving
to be incredibly tricky um I think if
you look at stage two in the intent for
stage two it's fine we're we're still on
track and we're doing what we we're in
cost budgets for that the roof um as I
started to intimate in my report it's
going to have to be locked at with a
separate sort of lens and we want
specialist in for that right yep and we
and I think it's going to you know grow
grow a little bit of arms and legs and
probably we'll we'll we'll break our
stage two budget but we will not break
the overall project budget and we'll
need to bring that information back to
council for them to make a decision on
that in a little bit later time okay
thank
you just question Le around um the
prioritization of the projects so um I'm
interested in counsil feedback on how
they see the pro what order of priority
the count the projects are versus sort
of where your guys are focusing on so
the your highest priority would be
obviously 1225 toara and the storage
facility yeah I think it's a it's a
great question I think look um they're
all they're all in Flight we're you know
we're working on them all all the time
yeah um I think that's probably a fair
answer to to give the team uh Brank home
is is is is up there as well it's a you
know it's a critical project it's been
on our books for a little while we
really do as a team want want to see
that through um absolutely the 1225
program is incredibly important to
council and very important to the staff
and as a program that needs to be
delivered well so it's not just a single
project no uh and then all the rest of
it is um you know sort of ba work for
the team you know they're committed to
it all um I I would like to say that
everyone in the staff will be thinking
about all their projects kind of all the
time so I don't I don't know if there's
a priority per se um we would definitely
prioritize anything else that was going
to come to our door um lower down than
what we're currently working on so I
think that's probably a fair answer yeah
and it's probably a little bit towards
and to lead into the next paper around
the CCTV you know clearly there's been
frustration around where we're not at
with that and you then picked it up um
and it's just probably how that will
phase into the project workflow and can
we get back on track yeah look
interesting comment isn't it yeah um
I've personally picked that up I'm not
intended yeah I've personally picked it
up myself in the sense that um I think
the team um as they currently stand have
got enough on the plate and they've got
enough to focus on and concentrate on
and I don't want to for them to take any
Focus off any of the current projects
that we're working on yeah uh I've
managed to pick it up and grip it up
really ly quickly uh and I've spent
quite a bit of time with safer cities
you know sort of getting them up to
speed and you know climbing into the
weeds a we bit on that to find out where
we're at and where we need to go uh
reasonably quickly with that yeah I'm
going to reach out to a number of
externals um so we're going to get some
external procurement support uh to help
me and help get the project back on
track so um yeah I'm I'm be recruiting
uh for for new project manager at the
moment quite short listed and we
hopefully uh we'll convert that person
pretty soon and get the bum on the seat
and and again build build some capacity
in the pmo yeah so looking at the world
today you'd be confident you can pick
that project up and perhaps get a he of
schedule again or get back on oh look I
think don't want to you know proceed my
report for a little bit later but you
know sort of set set out a timeline in
that report I'm not going to put a
report in front of you I don't believe
that we can do yeah um I wouldn't make
any promises today that i' I'd smash
that timeline D no that's right it's
just trying to understand the they're
all important as you say yeah rare sorry
do you have a question I think I reserve
it for okay now okay so I mean on the
point I think you were making um the
chair I think it's important that we do
understand if the pmo are finding itself
in a place where it's Happ to make
tradeoffs um because I think the
question you asked was you know where
where should the priority be given you
what kind of rank in order I think I'm
good assuming actually in the in the
plan that all of these strategic
projects getting done AR we yes we do so
I I think we're at pmo recognizes that
there has to be tradeoffs because you've
only get four engineers and you actually
need six to do the work I mean I think
it's really important that that comes
back to us so that we understand that so
that if there is a kind of ranking order
that we get we get an input into that
yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely I think
just to answer Tom's point there for me
it's about me you know expressing that
back to um eron through to Michael about
resourcing and making sure that the MO
is is you know serviced with the right
enough right amount of staff for the
projects that are inbound um like I say
at the moment we probably do want one
more person to the team and we're very
close to securing that person yeah um
which is you know a great a great thing
and I think at that point we will be
well set to not to compromise on on the
delivery or priority of any projects
that are currently in front of us yeah
yeah
okay uh thank you chair I think to Lee's
point he's had to Pi pick up that CCTV
one just around the capacity we are
close to securing um another project
manager but I guess I'd just remind us
that we've also got another key project
that we would like to be starting to
hand over into the pmo space um which is
obviously dependent on what happens with
the outcome um of es Street West um and
what happens with that project um that's
one that ideally we would have the pmo
quite heavily involved now in starting
to scope um up what we what we might do
in that space um again that's going to
be one where we're going to have to um
do as best as we can resour to trans
that one into team making sure
it's um because that's obviously a key
key priority for us as well yeah so so
the extra resource that's that's to take
account of that new project coming in or
um that's one of the the key projects
that we'd want that new resource to pick
up yeah so your sentes with that person
on board you can you've got enough
capacity to pick up CCTV and potentially
walk yeah I think look you know we can
you know we're not uh agnostic to what's
going on we we can see these projects
coming uh from a little a little way off
yeah so yeah no I believe that extra
resource will give us a good bit of
capacity and look tirey will be
delivered you know at the end of the
year um the toara will be you know
delivered well you know early part of
next year so we'll start to you know
we'll start to complete a few our
current projects too yeah so uh yeah no
I think I'm on balance and you got your
key person R covered sorry you've got
your key person R covered absolutely
good okay can I have H sorry oh just
it's um just a question about the
housing the fact that you had to that
you're still not closed weren't closed
in when the um flood went happen um how
far
behind
or not quite as far along as you would
like to be is the project no I think the
housing actually is just about on track
to be fair you know we just we just
weren't as closed in as we um you know
we could have been in in that weather
weather event and it was just a smart
move to move the staff off site no I
mean timing wise it's actually tracking
along quite nicely the contractor is
doing a good job um um keeping us well
informed quality is good so no it wasn't
it's not a case of it actually being
behind we lost a little bit of time on
Brank some uh because of that event um a
few days there but um no we we didn't
really lose any time for that it was
just a smart move at the
time thank you okay so no further
discussion or questions can I have move
in a second thanks Tom Barry moving
second any final okay all those in favor
of receiving that report I okay carried
right the tab eight the update for
CCTV now I think uh given that it's um
quite a Hot Topic I maybe just leave
that let let the report be read and yes
get into some questions questions so
Noby um so I just need need to clarify
uh what transpired at the last meeting
um that I exercise my Powers as a May to
um removed the previous community group
that we had around this project um and
that I will take the lead role on that
and I did that intentionally because I
think we've got to a point where the
community inputs no longer required and
we've got to a sto position as well
which is um not a reflection on the
committee but more reflection on their
internal Dynamics so I just needed to
clarify that um I've got a series of
questions relating to this yeah why yep
so um I guess the um first question for
me is on page 44 uh second paragraph in
which says uh um that we've got some
issues around the assumptions that other
stakeholders will fill will fund or
commit to the capital so I not heard
that in the year that we've had this
project going on probably more than a
year and we in one of our early meetings
we did approach the police and the
district Commander was here at the time
and said given that you want some
surveillance for security and given that
you want licensed plate recognition as
well would you consider some
contribution the answer was cl he
clarified it say no so I don't know who
the other external stakeholders would be
in this in this process um when I look
at the figures um we had an initial
budget of 800,000 that got moved uh more
recently to 1.1 and on the figures that
are presented today I think the overall
budget is by my assessment um
2.34 million plus 5 years to commit an
it worries me I guess that we have such
a large um movement in the cost of the
project and what I think most Council
around the table thought was maybe a one
or a two-year project is now a 5-year
project and I hear what uh lee was
saying about getting more project
management schill in it but look this
has been a disaster for us as a council
we've lost a lot of community Faith
around this uh I'll have to font a
meeting next week to explain to people
that we don't have the cameras available
in December like we gave a commitment
that we would have um so we've got to
have some confidence going forward and
um and so I guess I just wanted to
reflect that and and finally just to say
that um i' and rang is going to raise an
issue shortly um that I would like us to
have um some confidence to know where
we're actually are at the moment in
relation to the location of cameras and
how many we should have how quickly they
can be installed and what the software
is behind it because I think some of the
the advice we've been getting and that's
not a reflection on Lee but uh some of
the uh advice we've been getting is from
lay people as opposed to people that
have technical expertise in the field so
I'd like to know where we're what the
status quo is today where we're at so
I'll leave rangy to raise an issue about
that yeah okay thank you Le you on yeah
can go probably go through that so um
assumptions and stakeholders there was
there was probably some assumptions
within the team and within some of the
consultancies advice we've been getting
is that possibly police would F fund
some bits and pieces possibly their new
CCTV control room etc etc from that um I
couldn't find any evidence and I'm
looking back through um a lot of The
Correspondents that come through that it
wasn't that commitment so we've added
that to the I've added that to the
budget so that's why you know uh there's
some gaps in the budget there's also you
know there's been various assumptions
made around um VMS server base what we
would you where with that server would
be in some costings around that there's
also been some assumptions around
Network quality that we have throughout
the city and how easy or difficult it
would be to connect polls to our current
Network um we flushed that out a lot
more with the designers now at safer
cities and realized that there were some
gaps within that costings and we've had
quite a few um fairly in-depth workshops
with them and sort of I've really pushed
pretty hard on tasing out a lot of these
assumptions and with that we've tased
out probably what is more a realistic
budget
um with regards phasing the phasing here
um m clar is around what I see is a
budget that you've got on the books
right now so um it could go it could go
faster as long as the funds were
available I think that's probably a
comment I'd make and and that be in
stage two and three not stage one stage
one's putting all the bolt bolts the
bolts together to carry it so you're
going to have the view in the capability
in the network connection capability
plus the camera piece I think in
reflection for what I've what I've I've
sort of seen to date there's been an
over there been overly an emphasis on
where the poles were what cameras there
were going to be how many cameras they
were going to be in the different stages
that they would be at and whilst that's
great and it's given us a good Insight
it's probably allowed me to probably
grip this up pretty quickly and go right
that's what stage one looks like that's
what stage two looks like Hammer the
assumptions when it comes to costing and
actually start of really flush out some
of the bugs in that and sort of take
some more ownership on some of those uh
assumptions and
allows us then to deliver phases two and
three down the track if money become
available but what what I have found is
that for phase one which will cover your
VMS will cover your viewing ability
covers the network capability viewing at
Place viewing here uh and putting
cameras up on poles that's phase one is
the is the hard piece once you got phase
one done phase two and three are
literally are possibly running C
possibly running power cables possibly
running data cables putting cameras on
poles possibly upgrading a few polls
it's gets quite gets quite a bit easier
stage two and three stage one's probably
the hard the hard one um and probably
the most disapp disappointing one for um
for Council and where the and where the
frustrations at so so just to explain
your table on page 44 of
bbox um in the right hand column so
phase one you're now saying to get all
the infrastructure in place is 82,000
that's that's that's our our assessment
to date yep and then the addons come
after that yep
okay um is it a yeah just just a final
reflection I guess yeah um one of the
commitments we gave as a collective
council at the beginning of this term
was to um make sure we didn't go down
the slippery slide that we've been on
before and and I just I guess I'm just
giving a warning out to my colleagues on
this that we we've been lulled before
into projects that sound really great um
and project costs that sound great and
so you emotionally get committed into it
and the community gets excited about it
and then in this case the project costs
have basically trebled and the time
frames have at least doubled or possibly
more um so I guess that's some
accountability for us to make sure that
we get it right on I guess at the first
stage if we can don't bite off more than
we can fund don't bite off more that we
can't deliver on a reasonable time frame
yeah be tough on
yeah
R look um we'll go back to the previous
report about the projects and sorry the
answer on the 51,000 did not cut the
mustard with me it just did not
explain 51,000 really shows nothing um
and moving forward with what's
proposed in delivering this project I I
cannot accept The Way Forward um it it
really is
this what we need I believe right now um
and would satisfy the M concerned is a
is a second opinion and um of spoken to
some uh some industry Specialists
they've come up with a South Island
based consultant who I spoke to this
morning and would look at it for us for
for
$5,000 come
inago and he's he has done these systems
at the coldface he's worked with the
police he's done the control
rooms and delivered the projects
networks and everything he's not he's
not a high level consultant he he does
the work he makes it work and he can
advise us and he was happy to do this at
this particular price
now we look at what we what we got for
51,000 he would give us a comprehensive
report for five now I'm putting that to
council um look I'm I'm speaking from a
professional point of view because I
wouldn't be suggesting it unless I
absolutely believe so that this is where
we're
at so whether you want to alter
something on the um recommendations but
I believe we're at that crossroads now
and I think it' be dangerous not to get
that second point of view yeah so I
think there's a couple of things there
well there's I think we got to be really
clear on what that person would come in
and actually do so the scope of what
they're going to do are they going to
review
the um you know the document that's been
created no well yeah so that to my point
what are they actually going to do what
they've done is they've done I think
he's done done about 15 different cities
Municipal systems connecting to police
stations yeah I'm not doubting no no no
no but I'm just saying we need to be
clear on what what are we asking them to
come in and review what are we expecting
to get out of that review so no no the
review would be the network the way to
attack the network like from a person
who's actually held a screwdriver the
way to then look at the police
involvement what the police actually
want to look at because he's worked with
the police and what they want to see and
then we can overcome all these they're
all assumptions at the moment and we
really so in effect he would come and do
some advisory to the project around this
is where you are this is what you need
to get done so that we can have
confidence
that you know the the technical piece of
the actual user friendliness of the end
product is is effective well it's a bit
more than that actually you would get
you would actually get basically a
system designed you you know you would
you would actually get a lot for it um
just on his experience this is the thing
this is this is what I did uh in this
particular City it's like I mean if if
Council doesn't want to do it they don't
have to do it but I yeah the way we're
heading at the moment we are going
nowhere yeah so Le and then we'll park
back because I want to come back to a
couple other things cool probably a
little bit of um what uh Council P just
talking about is is that has been done I
mean safer cities have come down they
spent time with the police
they've located cameras they've staged
it out they've specified cameras they've
specified what they look at what poles
roughly they'll be located that but what
we don't have is the detail of that and
I don't believe anybody could can come
down and do that for the sort of money
that you're talking about but that's
that's going to be a lot of work then
there's the whole design you know we
talk about Design Network design we have
a conceptual design it's very much like
the museum we roughly know what it's
going to look like and you know we put
that to the public conceptionally in in
late February you had a concept of what
CCTV would look like you kind of roughly
knew what cameras you were going to have
you kind of roughly knew where they were
going to be and you kind of roughly knew
what sort of cameras they were going to
be and there was some high level costs
associated with that uh which which
formed the budget that's that's that's
part one of design we've got two more
steps to go through and we got to get
through those steps reasonably quickly
hence um in my report you know by
January we need to have all those needs
done
we don't have them you know we we have
limited information about our Network we
know where fiber runs but we don't know
how to get fiber from that duct up into
that pole we don't know if that pole
will be stable in the wind if it will
affect the NPR or APR camera if if the
visibility you know all that sort of
stuff now needs to go into a real high
level detail you know right a very
detailed amount of uh information so we
can put that out to the procurement put
that out to the market to go and get
that look
if someone if someone says they can take
a design from concept to detailed for
$5,000 that's that's a bargain I just
don't believe it can be done yeah okay
so um is your question related to this
one yeah yeah okay yeah
go um I mean it seems to me that this is
such a specialist field that if there's
somebody who's been identified who's got
expertise and has done it before then
you know we should not overlook that
opportunity and um clearly and it would
been appropriate for Council to
commission that work but I mean I think
council could certainly suggest to
management that they you know they look
at that opportunity and if for
$5,000 all you're going to get is some
general advice and um an opportunity to
look at how that individual works and
whether there might be value and so I
mean it I mean it's almost like a almost
like a job interview in some respects I
think $5,000 so it would be not not for
employment but for use in other parts of
the project so I mean it does seem to me
that we um could in fact I think we
already have since the councilor has
said so recommended to management that
they kep that consideration but we
should certainly not be commissioning
ourselves no no that's right um Darren
you your hand up before I think yeah I
had some I had have some real concerns I
I thought initially what council poder
was proposing was a peer review
of of what we had but it actually sounds
like more like here's a report on what I
can do in handing over the contract
which I think no no no no no it's a it
it is it is a peer review by a person
who does this stuff right and they would
potentially if we put it out to Tender
step back and then may apply just like
everyone else does I mean what you're
getting is an industry specialist who
does that snuffs of a conflict but I I
have no problem with a peer review and I
think a peer review might might be
useful but if you do a peer review you
can't
then tender bid for the bid for the job
yeah I think that's a conflict thank you
clarification yeah through yourself
cheer look we we're very open from a um
operation point of view for peer reviews
of if they are um something that council
is wanting in relation to certain
projects um what I would say with this
one was we have used people that um
specialty in their fields in relation to
the initial work and now we've handed it
over to our pmo for a delivery um aspect
because we had concerns around how the
project was um progressing and we wanted
to accelerate that I would note any
review will change your timeline because
you will need to go through that review
process and you'll have to time bound
that so you don't slow it up too much um
but with any project we do from
perspective of being open to getting
reviews both from governance and also
from an elot perspective with their
internal programs we hear projects that
we would say we want to review we're not
comfortable with us to um its path but I
you to I also go on the um same path in
relation to what um Council ller just
raised as well is that it does put you
in Conflict once you actually um
contracted to do a review you won't be
able to then put your name forward into
commission to do the work because you've
um you have conflicted yourself in
relation to that but we do have other
people that we do that and we we engage
with Specialties in that area um like I
say open to it if Council wants to go
down that um path uh the only suggestion
I say that will have a delay in relation
to it and we have already used experts
to get to this stage so I'm not sure
it's going to have a significant impact
but it could
um so I'd leave at the council to say if
they want us to do that then by all
means but um I would note the delay in
the time frame and with your Indulgence
I just want to highlight a
recommendation that you might want to
put in which um the M noted right at the
start which was to
um for the m to uh is nominating himself
to take the lead in relation to the
program I to the recommendation yeah
just add that as a recommendation three
so it's very clear
yeah what is it Ellen no I'm good now
thanks all good now yeah okay do you
want to just a quick one on the peer
review if I don't mind um look I think
um we typically use peer reviews if
we've got doubts or or or questions on
what
we're currently working with uh safer
cities have done this you know quite a
bit themselves too so when we're talking
about industry experts the we went out
for a pan we went out for a supplier and
safer cities were our chosen supplier
they are experiencing this pace um could
they done it a little bit better U I
think they probably would admit they
probably could could we have driven it a
little bit better I think we can admit
that we probably could have too um have
they been deficient in what they've
given us I don't believe so I think
conceptually it's fine it's got some
assumptions that probably weren't
weren't the best and um we could have
probably done that a bit a bit better
what the peer review would do you know
you could look back and you could find
problems with anything if you really
look back into things um it's about
moving forward and that's what this
report's about it's about telling you
what we've got to do in the next few
months and and we need to work hard to
get make sure that happens it's given
you a forward view of what it could cost
to operate a system and what it cost to
install all 133 cameras uh that I
believe is a lot more realistic than
you've ever probably had in front of you
uh since yeah so yeah so I think that's
I think that's the point I want to make
on peer reviews if the councilors don't
feel that the the advice they've got
today is not is deficient then we should
definitely do a peer review but
otherwise I don't see what the benefit
for yeah um so before I come to youself
me and also Darren just I think B and R
um you know there's three things here I
think we've is we've got to look at the
increased cost and say are we
comfortable with that we've got to look
at the time frame and give consideration
to that you know we're happy with a sort
of a fiveyear thing to m point and then
the phasing in terms of communities like
City and Bluff so um you know I think
there are three things that we need to
give direction to Lee and his team today
around you
know are we prepared to sort of suck up
the additional
cost um are we prepared to accept the
time frame and are we prepared to accept
the existing phasing of it so the other
sort of things I'm interested in getting
some feedback from the committee from um
and we need to make a decision those
three things pretty quickly so
no um so not easy to make the following
comments chair
um I'm not comfortable with the advice
I've got from staff as a group on where
we're at at the moment I think the buck
has been passed from infrastructure
across to the pmo office and that's a
reflection on the pmo um I don't know
how we can be comfortable with the cost
going from 800,000 not too long go to
2.34 million how it can go from what I
thought would be a year or two at the
most to get this right across the whole
network to be 5 years yeah and as you
quite rightly say the phasing
implications for South City and Bluff
which will be at the tail end of this
project um I'm just not comfortable
about that and I don't know who to
believe anymore um I've I personally
asked twice within the last 3 months for
assurances that we would have these
cameras installed in the CBD by December
because the public wanted to know at
Christmas time whether the CBD would be
safe and I got assurances that it would
be there subject to a comment that said
but it's a bit of a stretch which was
the quotation but a bit of a stretch and
now a 7 Monon delay and a doubling of
the cost is a stretch too far for me
yeah so I I would like somebody from the
industry to come here call it peer
review Call It Whatever You Like and
tell us cuz we've done nothing today
really nothing physical that the public
can see just to say hey look yes it will
cost you 2 and a half million least
right it will be 5 years not three years
or two years and yes you will need to
phe and that would give me some
confidence for that yeah okay so you're
in favor of a shorter time
frame no I'm in favor of getting
somebody down that's done this work
before and look I I can't understand how
we could not take somebody that's got
expertise CU this is a very narrow field
this this field who gives us some advice
but then cannot tender for the work
later on if you go to a doctor well I
mean some eyes being raised but I'd like
to know why not if you go to a doctor
and they send you to the specialist and
the specialist says well look here's the
technical advice on your illness and I
but sorry I can't operate on you now
because I've given you some technical
advice that doesn't seem right to me I
know in lots of places that the people
that initially give the advice
subsequently put their hand in
and I don't want any peerreview to say
this is what we've done wrong I know
what we've done wrong the delays are
stearing us all in the face all I want
to know is where are we at now yeah and
what uh what we can we realistically
expect down the track and how long will
it take I don't want to be here a year
from now to find out that the 2.3
million is now 5 million no or that we
got to cut back the cameras cuz we run
out of money yeah I want to know that up
front before we commit we should have
had it before yeah fault yeah late just
on that um conflict piece for the
mayor's um information as long as any
anybody that came in um was not uh
supporting a particular product they
Supply or a service they Supply there
wouldn't be a conflict for it um they
they would probably need to you know
where did we go wrong sort of scenario
where you go from here but they need to
remain agnostic when it comes to uh
technicalities equipment and and things
like that so I would be would you're on
on caution of of a peer reviewer or a
third party like that coming in and
designing a system for us but certainly
supporting us and pointing Us in the
right direction to keep us on track
would be uh probably useful to have us
extra pair of eyes to do that yeah who's
got a really specialist background
industry yeah okay good thank you R um
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to kind
of add to what the mayor has said and
others in the room I think there's
enough evidence to support having a peer
review given the fact that May's
dismissed his community group within
three weeks was so been appointed and
taken the Project Lead himself that in
itself to me um addresses a high concern
from from the mayor um I'm also um
thinking about the it's been said by
Council poser that he has an individual
that would have a budget allocation of
up to $5,000 to peer revie um the system
whether that's at um Grassroots levels
or recommendations or what have you um
and I I think that given the seriousness
to this um it would be quite wise of
this Council to go that way down peer
review um and I wanted to talk about
with the um example given from doctors
and assessing you then doing the surgery
this is a contra a contractual contract
to add a service to our community for
for sa communities it's it's by all no
means even simp even close to a doctor
um giving you a reference of what you
need for Ser then then doing that I
think it's probably not the right um
example to use um but I do think
that it's become quite a motive area
that we need to be careful that we just
don't get out of control too much with
that and put it into the context which
is the budget set is not going to be
enough and it's inreased the timelines
that we were promised and assured for
have not in fact um panned out due to
the fact that there's been assumptions
that weren't quite right um and I do
think that now that the um stage has
been set we need to get on with
it so so can I ask you in terms of your
time frame would you like to see it done
quick um I'd like to see it done in the
most timely manner possible with the
appropriate budget put to it and the
specialist that would be appropriate to
do that it didn't answer the question
that's your answer
Darren trying to figure out what we're
after
um magic or not attracting the attention
of the DIA or breaching our own
procurement process ex because at the
moment I'm hearing requests that cover
pretty much all of those um look we have
been told about the
potential crunch in and time all all the
way through and and I get and share the
frustration that this last one was a
beauty along with a um a
phenomenal jump in the actual cost but
as you go through most
projects some increase is is not
uncommon this degree is is reasonably
spectacular and I'm trying to understand
what it is that Council wants do you
want a peer review and I can see given
the change in where we are from where we
started it might be a good idea but or
do you want it in place as soon as
possible because peer review will will
slow things down um I guess the the
other option because I'm I'm equally as
intrigued at councilor p a suggestion of
somebody who has the potential to come
up with something that's pretty good of
that person tendering for the job and
coming with a variation that
is off what we were what was originally
scoped but if if they're able to tell
why there's that degree of variation and
why comes in at a lesser cost and and
quicker you know that that would be
great
um but my main concern in having a peer
review done if that business wants to
compete and let's face it doctors don't
go out touting for business we go to
them and specialists in in this area it
is a a business where there are
competing businesses as long as if we
could get through a process and not not
sure how we do without breaching our
procurement process that is our own
policy
and attracting the
DIA or audit through that I get that we
want it in place and we want it in place
yesterday which is in the magic category
now and my next fear is that April is is
going to be a
challenge um and and while it goes
through the summer without it it being
there nothing's going to change there at
at this point um no one's going to come
up with a system that can installed and
ready to go by by Christmas no so
there's a fair degree of sucking it up
that we're going to have to do the I
guess the thing with a peer review is
it's going to look back and I don't
think it's going to tell us anything we
don't know
no thinking I'm thinking is where are we
at and how do we move forward quicker is
what we're looking for right yeah
probably a couple of things TI add to
that is in the sense of that um experts
are typically experts
at their field of expertise funny they
call experts but project managers we we
tend to be a bit different in our sense
we'll we've got a broad range of we've
got a broad range of skills we we follow
a a process to ask the right questions
to flush out things I've built uh world
first fish farms and I've built hotels
and you know and everything in between
so I'm not an expert of Fish Farms or
hotels by the way but I've built a few
so that's what project managers are we
ask more we ask we ask the tough
questions we we climb into the weed
sometimes and we get up nice and high
and and helicopter it from the top
sometimes as well look when you put this
to the when you put this when I when I
sit in front of these guys and
interrogate what they've done and and
and and flush out those
assumptions you know I paint a different
picture the picture is more money more
time these expertise of these people
that rangy talks about they may be
experts at putting cameras up but they
won't be project experts and that's
where you know safer cities is probably
when when I've sort of gone through this
and done a bit of review on this with
them you know you assumed this that's
not quite right so what does that
actually mean in English oh you know it
means put some monitors up into the
police station maybe a room there's you
know the room is quite small needs a
bigger space all of a sudden you know
that's $ 10
$15,000 you know their project
management fee or their initial project
management fee was $20,000 or something
well you spent 50 already so how do how
how does that Stack Up and how much more
do you need so when you start
interrogating these these uh systems or
these these experts with the project
management lens and a wider lens you
know how do you get that cable from
there to there or you dig a pit who's
doing that oh not us I put cameras up
I'm a specialist in cameras oh so now I
need to get a civil engineer or I need
to get a civil expert to dig dig the
road up and put a cable from there to
there yes you will how did you had you
allowed that uh not not not really no
because we didn't understand how much of
that we need to do yet so that's not in
the budget Pro when project managers
interrogate system schemes like this and
I've done this a lot in my in my career
this is where you flush out these things
so whilst rang is expert would be an
expert on on cameras and look sa safer
cities are an expert on cameras they may
not have the full view on this and this
is why you know it's not an easy report
to read it's not an easy report to write
because we haven't done we haven't
showed ourselves in glory here at all
but you know this is tangible a peer
review might be tangible too what do you
want to take from
it
Michael yeah thank you through yourself
cheer um I'm actually going to go back
to the um surgery um or suron example no
no we're not going to have any more of
that no no I we're not because it's an
analogy that was played out and we it's
actually a very good analogy in relation
to where we're at CU When a surgeon has
a difficult case and they've got
problems solving that they go and they
consult with a a colleague they consult
with another specialist in relation to
that particular surgery or their
outcome and that would be your peer
review in the case of of a technical
solution we don't have we've got one
technical expert in relation to this um
project and they are providing the
solution council's now in the position
that they're saying they're challenged
with that particular project and they've
got concerns um fair and that's fair
enough I no one's at this stage
challenging um our project management
office and I and we've already said
we've got a good project management
office we're comfortable with that
approach so we're challenging the
solution that we've got there I'm
comfortable with us and with Council
putting in a um wanting us to do a
review in relation to the the advice
that we've received and that that is
going back and saying we we've we've
been working with a consultant we want
to just just double check that we're
getting the right advice and right
outcomes and Rel relation to that CU we
have a difficult Network and difficult
solution and we've had a proposal in
relation to an expert that could come in
I would suggest under your procurement
policy you actually uh um required to
actually do go out and get one or one or
more so you actually need more to put
into that piece and I would suggest
given um the M assigned himself as the
um the lead in relation to that that um
he therefore makes the call in relation
to which one we you want to go down in
um from that perspective so you actually
get a couple more experts into the
picture and say we're going to go with
this one and it may well be that one but
you want to cover those bases but I
think the analogy is actually quite good
when you think of it in those terms and
you're not looking at pmo you're looking
at the technical advice in relation to
completing the the work yeah so I think
that you saved yourself but I think
definitely but no one else needs to
raise that anymore thanks um it we're
looking not to perhaps review because I
think Lee's done a good job of that it's
actually looking for where we're at and
how we move forward quicker and a more
cost effective way that's what we want
someone to come in and give us some
external view on that's fair isn't it
well we've actually started that so I've
provided back to safer cities engineer
quite a bit of information over the last
three four days I'm meeting with I'm
meeting with the police next week um
with a CCTV um person there yeah um I've
also intimated to them there's a a bit
of a CCTV police Guru based up in Christ
Church who I've worked with before and
I've tried to connect those two officers
together and he's going to uh he's going
to do that so he can get a bit of a
learnings from Christ Church as well and
we've also offered to travel up there
and go and you know meet with that
officer who I've met before who runs
this or looks after the CCTV up in
Christ Church as well so we we we're all
you know we're already climbing into
this we're climbing into the weeds of
this we're getting into the detail um
that's that's what we're doing we're
doing that as fast as we possibly can
uh yeah Tom yeah look this will sound
really simplistic but to me if the mayor
and and the chair of infrastructure
committee wish for an independent review
to be done carried out on a
infrastructure
project then it should be done yeah
yeah yeah and and if you know and that
that individual is obviously an option
maybe there's other options but but I I
I'm uncomfortable with the push back
that we're getting chair to me you know
chairman infrastructure committee the
mayor has asked for something to be done
yeah then that should be decent enough
yeah I don't think there's any push back
yeah it's just probably more clarifying
what what's this person going to
actually doing it's a look forward as
opposed to look back yeah yeah okay is
there any final comments I've got Evelyn
Barry Ry Le the enroy you got 30 seconds
each oh BL to um
um really uncomfortable
with the appearance of us getting into
management as oppos the
governance but thanks Darren for what
you said because that was something that
was in my mind just for me I think it's
that this
project is probably bigger and more
complex than we
originally had thought it would be and I
probably count myself amongst the naive
because I thought that it would be
relatively straightforward so the fact
that it is more complex that the cost is
greater that um that it's going to take
longer is all disappointing but I think
we shouldn't lose sight of why we went
down this track in the first place so
there's concerns about safety in the
inner city um and but the the things
that concern me that are going to be
left waiting are the really costly
things like the extreme damage at places
like Sterling Point which looks like it
going to be the nearly last thing off
the block now it might sound silly that
I'm talking about that but an actual
fact that is one of the faces of this
town that people come from all over the
world to be photographed there and it's
very often not in a fit state if we
don't put cameras there soon what is the
cost we're facing what are the other
risks we're facing so these are all the
things I'm thinking of we've got to get
to the point where all those places that
we value and all the people that we
value feel are safe and are comfortable
and if that takes a bit longer and if
that needs a little bit more
examination perhaps that's what we need
to do instead of thinking that the
answer is going to be simple and
cheap bar yeah I don't usually agree
with Evelyn but I do in this respect big
time I was at the bluff community board
last night and they expressed their real
concern that this is being dragged back
and back and back and they right at the
back of the field uh I really appreciate
what you're doing Lee because you're
really good at doing all the sort of
work but I also back what Tom said that
I think we should get that other advice
yeah R look I wasn't going to play this
card but you know sometimes when it
chips it down
um over the weekend because I don't have
a life um I actually priced out an
entire system for the city using a
police rated camera has checkpoint
security which is the highest level Inda
approved
everything uh a
network uh system in the control room
the whole lot came to $870,000 that's
230 cameras now the reason that is why
I'm questioning what we're doing because
if I can do that from just sitting at
home with the price thing that I have
Avail available to myself then it throws
a huge bloody Shadow over the the
figures that have put in front of me
sorry and that's why I want this second
report yeah because I did the sums and I
look I allowed 50 nights at the langland
staying there drinking fine wine you
know for the installer so you know you
look this doesn't add up the pricing
does not add up so that's why I am
raising it if if the pricing had come
out something else then fair enough I
accept all of this but sorry um I just
can't sit here and accept the way it's
been done yeah your pricing is for the
cameras and
the the G right so you work everything
so all the holes and everything
everything everything and this and this
is where and this is where this went
wrong yeah all right that's this is
where safer cities have got it a little
bit wrong and unfortunately C the the
penger really got it a little bit wrong
unfortunately in this but you have to
connect it all up yeah and once you
connect it once you look to connect it
all up once you look to view it properly
where you going to view it how you going
to view it it's it's a lot more than
that someone not listen to but I'm but
I'm happy to I'm happy to take those
numb look we think we've enough um so we
I think we need to bring um you know
into Tom's point you know we've got some
pretty strong recommendations from Cher
of infrastructure and the May around
bringing someone into look at where
we're at how we move forward and flesh
out some of these pain points um to
support the work you're doing Le so how
do we get that on the paper someone to
move a recommendation someone to move a
recommendation we will draft the uh
resolution you still had
speakers you get indicated all right
sorry do you want to speak then yes
thank you I think there was someone else
after me as well no there's not we got
no no I with through my question it have
been
answered before before any any further
um as put forward I just wanted to say
it seems to me at this point that you
had asked for for several
indications
um seems to me that the moment we asked
the project management office to take
this project on we were effectively
asking for a peer review and what we
have been delivered today is the results
of that the the very index investigation
into the gaps and the assumptions the
filling in of those and basically a road
map that gives us a timeline yes we
would like to speed up that timeline
what I don't want to see is that the
timeline is slowed down in any way I'm
really reluctant to have to refer to
back of the envelope calculations but
this is the danger of counsellors in the
governance role putting themselves into
the management space none of us as
Governors should be coming to the table
with back of the envelope
calculations we gave a project into the
hands of our project management office
and asked them to come back to with a
report that gave us a road map forward
as quickly and as indepth as possible
and with costings that we knew were
going to be robust that's what we've got
I would like to see us move forward with
it with it I'm really reluctant that we
put a roadblock into the timing and that
we appear to be questioning the project
management office skill to actually dig
deeper into this project so I'm very
uncomfortable as Governors that we step
into the management space on a project
where we've now got a clear timeline and
a clear Way Forward it's what council
asked for and it's what we can actually
manage if we want to speed up the last
couple of years perhaps we indicate that
but let's get it let's get stage one
underway yeah look I I think I think I'm
in support of having someone come in um
you know we've been bitten and I don't
think it's in any way Affliction on the
pmo office I think Lee's done a really
good job to pick this up really quickly
and dig into it and as you say dig into
the wordss and find some question marks
which is flared up in air mines and we
we need reassured around cost
particularly and also um to support Lee
in terms of if we can get the done
quicker at a cheaper cost then we need
to look at that at this point because
we've spent eight months thinking
everything's on track and it isn't in so
um I'm looking for someone to put a
motion or resolution for um I'll go for
you the M read the one clarification I
just need to be sure that when we're
seeking to use the person that um rangy
has suggested he's got this background
in doing both chross church and
Orland no he isn't an Orland oh he's
like he's just don't work y That's okay
I mean
obviously it this is not he's not just
done cameras he's project managed he's
done the entire lot so I I don't
appreciate people belittling the
capabilities of someone who various
councils have just employed to do their
job now um so yeah sorry
mayor so um my my question I guess is
that
um if I wanted a legal opinion out of
Simpson gon for argument sake and we
approved getting a legal opinion we
wouldn't go to a procurement process for
a $20,000 piece of legal advice and what
we're asking for here is possibly a
$5,000 piece of advice and we go to a
procurement policy which means that we
go out and try and get more than one one
source of giving us the advice we've got
somebody that can give us a snapshot and
tell us where we're at and what the
Horizon look likes for us then we can go
forward that was not my point no I don't
think anyone said we're going to go
through a procurement process well no I
raise procurement process to make sure
that we don't shft no no one saying we
go through a process like that
okay right I said did you want to
propose a
resolution
ringent I'll I'll do one yeah and people
can have a play with it if they want to
um so recommendation three is that we um
we engage a choss based consultant no
Southland base right Southland base
consultant at a cost of $5,000 plus GST
to assess our current
position and assess the way forward
with funding needs time
frames and capacity of the
network do you want to add to that can I
can I wiggle a wedding yes you can
propose a budget of up to 5,000 Plus us
to youy with that I just cuz up to is a
cap yeah that's I'm f with
that
okay that up now yeah the only
other point is did you have a time frame
that you wanted that report back noting
some of the advice you have received
from both the chief executive and the
pmo director yeah around how many
potential delays by doing this I'll have
to ask Ry that ringy what's the
potential time
frames I would have to I'm not going to
commit to anything I'd have to come back
to you may think if I wouldn't mind if
you would mind chair um I think this was
wants to be done concurrently to what
we're doing so yeah I think that's what
I'd like to propose to everybody is that
this is done concurrently with what
we're doing I don't want to stop safe fa
cities to doing what they're doing sure
we've we've got to we've got to get this
needs assessment flushed out so we get
the procurement so I can get a
contractor putting cameras up can I can
I suggest sorry for you that I mean I
wonder whether this requires a
resolution if we have the um pmo office
manager saying that he will arrange to
have that done then my suggestion would
be that we simply accept that and we
don't make any resolution it's when you
make a resolution this start to go into
you know Leslie's point about um yeah
you know eating Le
lunch I think if Lee SE will do that
then I would just accept that and let's
have it done it is a legitimate option
in function of the pmo to call in advice
the pmo has received advice from the
Council of what it's looking to see so
you're pretty clear on what we want yeah
no if the committee chair can pass
through that information then we can we
can action it yeah no you happy with
that giving you the lead now yep cool
why we're rcy then let's do it and um we
will make the uh changes to the
governance statement necessary to
formally appoint the mayor into that
role um at the upcoming council meeting
on the 31st because only Council can
change the governance
yes okay so we we don't need anything
so so can have a move in a second for
Ria and Barry thank you so any final
comment but all those in favor of those
two recommendations in the guidance to
poo I
against carried right
thanks public excluded thanks Le um so
we're now going to move into public
excluded and a summary of the reasons
for that primarily uh to under the
various sections of
that
um The Local Government Act uh privacy
and Commercial sensitivity and they're
summarized in the paper so can I have
some move that we go to public
excluded thank you 72 I 72 I it is
thanks Darren second Tom okay all those
in
favor okay Carri right we have a five
minutes